[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم معكم سفيان ثابت ونستعرض معا
ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي لايجازه وفي
نشرت
مقتل نائل يشعل فرنسا مكه تفيض بالحجاج
نتنياهو يدعو لاشتكاك فكره اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه واخبار اخرى نتابعها معا
البدايه من فرنسا التي تشهد احداثا ساخنه
على خلفيه مقتل مراهق فرنسي من اصول
جزائريه برصاص الشرطي في منطقه ضواحي
باريس حيث اندلعت مواجهات واعمال عنف بين
محتجين والامن الفرنسي في مدن عتا الرئيس
الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون توعد بالتعامل بحزم
مع من يهددونه اساس الدوله الفرنسيه على
حد تعبيره وفي سياق متصل فرضت اربع مدن
فرنسيه بمنطقه ايليف حضرت تجول الليلي كما
اعلنت الداخليه الفرنسيه نشره 45 الف شرطي
واليات مدرعه وثقيله للتصدي للمظاهرات ومن
جانبها طالبت الامم المتحده فرنسا بمعالجه
مشاكل العنصريه والتمييز في صفوف قوه
الانف اذا فوضى في عمان فرنسا منذ ايام
لكن كيف ستتعامل الحكومه مع غضب الشارع
خاصه في بلد يشهد باستمرار موجات احتجاجيه
من السترات الصفراء ثم ازمه الى قانون
اصلاح التقاعد هذا ما سنسال عنه مراسل
الجزيره محمد البقالي
مرحبا محمد اذا ما خيارات الحكومه
الفرنسيه حتى لا تزداد الاوضاع سوءا
معقده لان
الامور قد انفلتت من عقالها بالنسبه
لاولويه عوده
السيطره على اعمال العنف هذا الامر قد
يتحقق بعد ايام قد تطول او تقصر من خلال
اللجوء الى الخيار الامني ولكن
ما يجب الانتباه اليه هو ان اعمال العنف
انما هي عرب لازمه اكبر وهي ازمه احساس
هؤلاء الشبان في الضواحي باللامساوات
وبغياب العداله وبانهم يعيشون على هامش
الحياه الاجتماعيه بان قطاره التنميه قد
مر دون ان يركبوه وبالتالي فحل الازمه
الحقيقيه لا يكون الا بالتفات لهذا
الاحساس العميق بغياب المساواه وهو ما لم
تفعله لحد الان الحكومه الفرنسيه او ربما
لا يبدو انها راغبه في الانتباه لهذا
الامر شكرا محمد
في اول ايام عيد الاضحى المبارك السلطات
السويديه سمحت لمتطرف بحرق نسخه من المصحف
الشريف في العاصمه ستوكهولم ما تسبب بغضب
اسلامي وتمديد عالمي واسع وخروج مظاهرات
في دول عده كما دفع منظمه التعاون
الاسلامي للدعوه لعقد اجتماع طارئ لمناقشه
القضيه وادانا الاتحاد الاوروبي بدوره
الواقعه ووصفها بالعمل المهيني
والاستفزازي في حين نددت السويد باقتحام
سفارتها في بغداد واعتبرته امرا غير
مقبوله عن تفاصيل ما حدث في السفاره
السويديه في بغداد ساسال مراسل الجزيره
سامر يوسف الذي واكب الحدث
سامر اهلا بك اخبرنا اذا بتفاصيل ما جرى
سفيان الاحتجاجات بدات عاقبه تغريده لزعيم
التيار الصدري دعا فيها الى مظاهرات امام
مبنى السفاره السويديه تجمع انصار الصدر
هناك واقتحموا البوابه الخارجيه ووصلوا
الى الباحه الداخليه لمبنى السفاره شوهد
خروج موظفين وايضا دبلوماسيين سويديين من
هناك تكرر المشهد في اليوم التالي ولكن من
دون اقتحام اكتفى
المتظاهرون بحرق اعلام المثليين ونددوا
بحرق المصحف الشريف شكرا لك سامر الان الى
موضوع اخر حيث دعا رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو الى العمل على
اجتثاف فكرته اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه
وقطع الطريق على تطلعات الفلسطينيين
لاقامه دوله مستقله لهم وربا على تصريحات
نتنياهو اكدت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه ان قيام
دوله فلسطينيه مستقله عاصمتها القدس
الشرقيه هو الحل الوحيد لتحقيق الامن
والاستقرار واعتبر ان حياته دليل على
حقيقه النوايا الاسرائيليه الرافضه
للشرعيه والقانون الدوليه كنا قد سالناكم
هل يؤثر تصريح نتنياهو باشتاف فكره اقامه
دوله فلسطينيه على علاقه اسرائيل مع الدول
العربيه المطبعه معها وكانت نتيجه التصويت
كالاتي اذا 25% قالوا نعم فيما قال 75%
وصوتوا السجال بشان التمرد الذي قامت به
شركه فاجنر تواصل الاسبوع الماضي ومنذ
احتواء الازمه بواسطه بلاروسيه لم تتوقف
انتقادات الدول الغربيه لروسيا ولشركه
التي عملت كادراع عسكري لها خصوصا في
حربها ضد اوكرانيا وعن القول ان ما حدث
يدل على التصدع داخل النظام الروسي في
المقابل ردت روسيا على التصريحات الغربيه
ووصفت ما حدث بمجرد مشكله مؤكده انها
دائما ما تخرج من الازمات اكثر قوه حسب
وصفها في الرابط باول تعليق فيلم استقصائي
يتحدث عن بدايات تكوين مجموعه
وارتباطاتها بالكرملين كما يستعرض مختلف
العمليات التي قامت وتقوم بها في عدد من
دول العالم الى بريطانيا وتطورات خطه
ترحيل طالب اللجوء المثيره للجدل حيث قضت
محكمه الاستئناف بعدم قانونيه خطه الحكومه
لترحيل اللاجئين الى رواندا بعد دعوى
رفعتها جمعيه حقوقيه قالت فيها ان الخطه
ستعرض حياه طالب اللجوء للخطر رئيس
الوزراء قال انه يحترم قرار المحكمه لكنه
قرر الطعن فيه امام المحكمه العليا وزيره
الداخليه البريطانيه سويلا بريفيرمان وصفت
قرار المحكمه بانه مخيب للامال وقالت ان
الحكومه ستتحرك للرد ردود فعل كثيره اعقبت
التطورات الاخيره ونرصد لكم بعضا منها
خالد الكناني يقول من المنطق والعدل ان
يكون على راس قائمه المبعدين ريشيسوناك
ووزيره داخليته اما ابو عابد فقال استغرب
من اللي يلوم هم فقط منفذين لاوامر اصحاب
السلطه العليا في البلد هذول موظفين صغار
سياسه الدوله العميقه في بريطانيا اغلاق
باب الهجره الى بريطانيا ولو تولى هذا
الامر مسؤول ابيض بيقولوا الانجليزي عنصري
لذلك جابوا مسؤولين من اصول مهاجره حتى
يبتعدوا عن الحرج بعد ثلاثه مواسم مقيده
باجراءات مواجهه كورونا الحج يعود الى
الوتيره العاديه حيث توافد ضيوف الرحمن
الى مكه المكرمه في موسم وصف بالمميز طبعا
افضل من يحدثنا عن هذا الموسم زميلنا بدر
الربيعان الموجود هناك
بدل ارحب بك اذا من خلال مشاهداتك حديثنا
اكثر عن اجواء الحج هذا العام
ما تميز به حج هذا العام هو التقنيه تم
الاعتماد على تطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي
لقياس واداره حركه الحديد وبلحظه وصولهم
عبر الملف الدوليه المختلفه الجويه
والبريه والبحريه وحتى لحظه مغادرتهم
اضافه الى ميزه اخرى لحج هذا العام وهو
تطبيق ايضا مبادر الطريق مكه ولا تستفاد
منها ما يقدر
يقول حاج قديمه من عدد من الدول المختلف
وتهدف هذه المبادره الى انهاء الاجراءات
الرسميه لجموع الحديث قبل وصولهم الى
المشاعر
شكرا لك بدر ومعك نختم هذه الحلقه من
ايجاز الاسبوع الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]